ce départ parce que la consommation de
viande et d'autres produits animaux
disparaîtra que ces animaux
disparaîtront pas de sens parce que si
vous voulez ce sont des deux décisions
distinctes
si vous décidez de comment dire de
d'introduire les animaux du pour
d'autres finalités dans la société
humaine que la viande et des risques
sont là tout simplement
vous commencez par dire que on commence
par la viande et on finit par les chiens
mais encore je vous ai dit ça c'était
une position très minoritaire c'est
parce qu on abolit la viande qu'on va
depuis avoir de chien par exemple vous
parlez des chevaux oui je connais des
gens qui font des cubes de l'équitation
qui sont antispécistes alors certains
antispécistes vont se plaindre
enfin moi je n'y vois pas d'inconvénient
du moment que c'est dans une relation
qui est équitable sans violence et c'est
bon je sais que c'est souvent pas le cas
mais on peut concevoir que ça puisse
l'être on peut concevoir un monde
animalistes antispécistes dans lequel
ils devront pratiquer l'équitation et
que ça ne poserait pas de problème est
en tout cas les problèmes s'ils
s'imposaient serait réglé bon donc il ya
mille façons d'intégrer les animaux pour
d'autres finalités que l'abattoir que
dont jocelyne porcher elle même un
instant dit que ce n'est pas bien pour
l'animal et çà de là dessus on peut au
moins s'accorder vous dites ces aliments
ne les verra plus et les met les gens
voit-il ces animaux ou simplement je
veux dire la grande l'immense majorité
de ces mots vous ne les voyez pas ils
sont derrière d'aider des bâtiments
d'élevage intensif
d'accord vous supprimez tous ces
bâtiments vous ne ferez vous ne verrez
pas la différence vous verrez juste
moins de camions ont passé vers les
abattoirs c'est tout donc encore une
fois le peu d'animaux en rang
proportions là la minorité d'animaux qui
sont élevés dans des conditions non
concentrationnaire pourrait tout à fait
je crois que c'est parfaitement
concevable pourrait pourrait
parfaitement exister d'une autre manière
pour d'autres finalités dans nos
sociétés
[Musique]